yeah yeah it's a bubbleless bubble just
like it's the gateless gate
right yeah yeah the veilless veil the
gateless gate
yeah wow
gosh that's such a fascinating yeah it
is
and because it comes right back to what
you were talking about
with the simultaneous
hey everyone welcome to simulation i'm
your host atlas
i'm super pumped for this episode
we are going to be talking about
non-duality and awakeness
we have fred davis joining us on the
show hi fred hello atlas thank you for
having me
i'm excited to be here me too i'm so
so excited for this conversation i've
been a huge fan
and it's been great yeah it's been great
to
be able to take in all of the different
ways that you're
pointing to the one end from the
different faces
of the mountain and yeah that's been an
analogy that we've been using a lot on
our on our show as well
and it's helpful because we sort of get
one of the ways aspects of the pointing
from one of the pieces of video or books
and then we get another one from another
pieces of video or books and then that
sort of
for each of us is our own unique style
of
that finding or awakeness of that
diamond necklace that's already around
our neck
yeah so uh for those that don't know
uh fred davis is a non-dual spiritual
unteacher five-time author
creator of the living method of
spiritual awakening and
awakeningclaritynow.com and you can find
that link in the bio below as well as
his amazon author page
and his youtube page which has a lot of
great free content
fred let's start off with this this has
been something interesting
for me that i'm really looking forward
to hearing how you feel about
so this idea of
true simultaneity being something like
in the most
layered approach to this we can say that
there's the
non-duality there's the ineffable
and it just is and it's this appearance
happening cool and then there's another
layer
and that's like the dualistic concession
which is something like there's
suffering and there's well-being
and we should eradicate as much
planetary suffering and maximize
planetary abundance and well-being
and flourishing and prosperity and
whatnot
so i'm curious
there's eight billion of us
and each of us are going through our own
unique
sort of piercing the veil god
realization
to that diamond necklace around her neck
and so if we hold all 8 billion
perspective simultaneously in that range
of where people are
at in this sort of spectrum how how do
you
take in an idea like that true
simultaneity of holding all of this
at once well it's the
obviously it's not a character's uh
ability to do so
what the same thing that's looking
through these eyes
is the same thing that's looking through
those eyes you just met my wife betsy
and it's the same thing that's looking
through her his eyes
and i just her heard my dog willie
barking and it's the same thing that's
looking through his eyes
simultaneously yes now
uh remember one time i had a session
with somebody and i happened to say you
were
the salmon swimming upstream i just came
out and
he said i can't see the sarah i can't
see us why can't i see us the salmon
why can't i see as willy yeah yeah
that's right
as willie and uh i said well you can see
what's going on just like you can see
what's going on
behind the the camera in this room and
all that
and i said but you're just not using
that unit to do it you're using this one
to do it
and you're using you are using the fish
to see as the fish
but all of that is coming to you now
what we hit here
is we hit something that just jumps
right on past right on past logic
because what we're really talking even
the 8 billion we can't we
there's no way the mine can really get
eight billion
uh and then we look at the universe
and we see that
it is it's either limitless or expanding
depending on which scientist you talk or
both i guess depending on which
scientist you talk to
whatever the idea is
these little things in our head right
these brains
i use this to show them
what you got here is you got three
pounds
but you got the most arrogant three
pounds
because that little piece affinity
actually believes that it can
encompass infinity
and it can't hold infinity which is what
it's always trying to do
we can only use that brain to behold
infinity
and it's quite a difference so
it's not a matter of understanding this
but
i'm i always tell people i'm not the
answer guy i'm the question guy
and that people will say fred would you
please explain that to me and i i
decided
we'll have you know paid some money to
talk to me
and i know it's very disappointing when
i tell them
well i can't expect you because i don't
understand it
but that's the truth i don't understand
you can't put this together i get it
i know that that i am this i know that
this
is not uh that i know that i am not
other than this but i also know i'm not
limited to this
and i'm certainly not limited to one of
these but
that has been the programming
is you know right right our parents
begin to
train us fred
mama fred daddy fred fred's room
and we go on and on the brainwashing
goes on and
we finally somewhere between 18 months
and three years we
we entered that agreement we entered
that lie
yeah this is actually the and a key
topic that i've listed as well that i
want to talk about
what you just said there was
really resonant that
the this this
this this i tend to laugh
the cosmic joke it is i know it's leela
right the divine play
that's it right yeah the
the three pounds the most egoic three
pounds
it's so funny yeah that's arrogant yeah
arrogant arrogant yeah arrogant three
pounds
it's so funny and
there's this there's this
there's this impulse is like to
to go in all the way to
our source and to know
that and to have that be
although at this nondual level it's this
ineffable mystery
at the same time there's the seeking
impulse to be like
hold all of infinity at once but
it is just this it's the beholding of
this expression
of that that is the sort of it's like
in the eye it's the you know the
the like you were saying it's the one
observer and the
that's shared among us and and that the
pupil
the pupil itself is that shared
component
and then the iris is the unique
coloration
of that expression the appearance of the
expression and so
maybe before we get into some of that
youthful
stuff how does the how do these like
kind of
you child like explain like i'm five
analogies how do they resonate when we
say like the pupil
is like the eye of god and the iris is
like the unique coloration or
well i don't actually talk about that so
it's it would be but i can explain my
view of things
yes and my view of things
is you were talking about the necklace
around our necks
but you probably know the story of
injuries net
and just in case anybody out there
doesn't let me tell it very quickly
so indra is the the is the
head of all the of hindu theology
uh mythology it's he's the king god if
you will
and the intro was there before anything
was there
and um andrew had a necklace like you're
talking about
and uh or he had and he took
it and we had a net that was like a
bunch of necklaces together
and he took that net and he flung it out
into the void
and when he did that all the stars
appeared
and in the that's the way it looks from
here
but from the nets view what you see is
that
there's a net and at every juncture
of the of a net like a fishing net right
every juncture
of that fishing net there's a jewel yes
exactly just like just like alex gray's
net of being
his visual that he has i'll i'll embed
that here for
for people okay it's it's super and i'll
also send it to you it's it's a really
good
visualization of what we're describing
yeah yeah good
yeah i have some visuals i have some
artist renderings
of something approaching that idea
here in my desk that i show people
sometimes so
the the thing is is that when we look
what we want to do is we want to look
at every jewel what can what is
it that every jewel can see
and what i'm going to suggest that every
jewel
that each jewel it sees
it can see every other jewel but it
can't see itself
like the eye can't see itself and
there's a
so each one of these jewels has a
zillion reflections
but nowhere with any in any of these
jewels
is there a center thing is there is
there anything in the middle it's the
jewel
itself meaning that this happening this
is
the jewel right and i can't actually
find
i like to report i'm very conservative
in what i report outlandish too but
um what i can truthfully report to you i
can't really tell you that i am i can't
tell you i'm not
but it's that's really out of my pay
grade what i can tell you
is that there's a sense of being here
that much i can report whatever it is
that's saying i
yeah it's lost in the loop but there is
that there is the sense of being here
yeah and but what i've noticed in my
inquiries is that the sense of something
doesn't necessarily equate with the
truth of something
in other words i had a i had a sense
this morning it was going to rain like
crazy and it dries a bone out there so
that's a wasted sense
and it's a sense that that did not
indicate anything that was true but it
was the sense
and what i'm saying is that there's a
sense of being but that's not same thing
as stating
i am or there is being there's a sense
of being that's it
that's as far as we can go down that
path that is the
that that sense of being
is the last thing we see
prior it's the first thing we see out of
the non-dual gate and it's the last
thing we see
in the non-dual gate in the as we move
back and forth between those two i ann
is thought to be that but i'm saying
there's something deeper and more primal
than i am
which is the sense of being and there's
something below that sense of being
but i have no idea what it's it's
it i want to know it well what i can
know is that i'm it
i can't i know i can't not be it but i
can't
know it from afar because there's only
it
it can't it's like oneness looking for
oneness with what everybody's doing in
the seeking community right
one is looking for again white to merge
with oneness yeah
the fish in is in the ocean yeah that's
it yeah
right exactly so what is there outside
of oneness that could merge with oneness
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i like how
you bring in this really
important visualization of this
this net of being
and how you also mentioned this this
just sense of of presence
this
that simply is
this happening now
in that visualization
it's really profound where we see
that every single one of those in the
net
every single one of those intersecting
points is the diamond
that is around each of our necks
right and then that that source light
shines through that unique diamond and
refracts
as a unique color combination
in that in that iris and so
that's yeah and so i'm not agreeing or
disagreeing
it's a theory that i know nothing about
so
talking about the ineffable yeah
right i just don't know about the iris
and people but that's fine if that's
your if that's your line of
of study i'm perfectly amiable with it
it's just an analogy it's just a
child-like analogy because the pupil
itself is just that dark
right that same shared dark across all
eight billion
but the iris is uniquely colored across
the okay okay
okay yeah yeah it sounds like you're
[ __ ] and the diamond that's around
each of our necks
is is the same it's the
that diamond is a diamond across all of
ours but then it's refracting a unique
expression or yeah yeah right so what it
amounts to is that
because in nonduality too often when i
and i now agree i'm just going to agree
what you're talking about
with the i thing i was kind of lost
there but
the with nonduality
we come to sense
that there is um
we we come to sense that there's
something
and there's our sense initially is that
but we're not connected to it
that's the idea because we think
ourselves to be a separate being over
here
not part of andrew's net but a separate
being a distinct being
and we think that we are um
disconnected from source if you will or
whatever we just begin to get that idea
as we move into non-duality and then if
we're not careful the easiest move to
make
and is it's important once we get past
the witness stage
because there's there's witnessing but i
can't find a witness
right i've looked and i just can't
and um so i would say there's
there is witnessing that much i can
attest to
um but as we move as we become to see
that the whole
wiz uh the whole
concept of a looker or watcher or
whatever that that's really just another
thought in the end
and so
there is
there's a there's a feeling like
i can come to know that but
who's that eye that's saying that
i've not found that odd i have done the
inquiry with
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
people and none of us have
ever found that eye i've had a few
people that did
uh report that they found an eye and
they didn't wake up but uh the people
that were with me who did find the eye
which was
almost everybody did find it and did
come
just did come uh they
came to see that there was no eye yes
go ahead it's probably a good
time to bring in this analogy that we
also use for this
part and it includes the the youthful
component that we were mentioning
earlier as well
which is that when
when the child
when the infant comes in to to the world
yes that in a sense
it already is the ocean it already is
absolutely and then that programming uh
especially that like around 18 months
there's that object
permanence that kicks in there's these
layers of identity
if it's not if it's conscious parents
then
the then there will be no drop that
forms
and but if the parents are unconscious
and if
especially because the civilization
itself is unconscious
that then what happens is that these
layers like onion layers or like the
drop
itself this bubble as you describe also
in your teaching that it forms
and then the bubble we can call that the
egoic contraction of energy that
separate entity
is what ends up seeking because it's the
drop
that doesn't realize that it's in that
it's in the ocean whereas
if you take like the the kogi mamas you
know or whatnot
they never undergo an experience of of
being anything other than the ocean
yeah right and and so so
so now what usually happens is you get
these like let's say 25 year olds or
whatever
and they're like what's the nature of
reality i'm not just this egoic
contraction am i i'm not a biological
finite creature
and so then they go seeking and seeking
and and there's
more and more direct paths now where you
don't have to do 30 years
at a monastery and so
so what happens is that that in the
analogy the drop
gets you know that bubble gets popped
and that's what usually what people say
when they're like oh everything is
oneness
you know it's all unity oh i get that
and so then
there's that stage so most of the
approximations with things like spiral
dynamics and david hawkins's levels of
consciousness as well
is that there's approximately 85 or so
percent
of civilization that's living in a
state of some of some sort of like egoic
contraction of identity and then about
maybe 14 or so percent
actually pop that and experience the
oneness or the unity but
then what happens is there's the
recognition that when you're the
the ocean this observer or the witness
or the i
am or the self is shared so you
recognize that we are the ocean
that is experiencing the waves and the
waves are the
thoughts feelings emotions perceptions
sensations
that type of stuff that's like the
clouds in the sky
and so all these different analogies for
it and then there's the last and there's
about 14
or so of people there and then this last
layer which is like the one percent
layer which is what you can say is the
absolute or the
ineffable which is when you sort of
recognize that even
there is no agent there's no attributes
whatsoever
this the dream or the illusion or the
appearance or what what happened
how do you feel 14 or 15 might be a
little high
for even the oneness for even the
oneness
for not for um
as many people wake up i think most
people wake up at some point in their
lives
and but it's a brief passing through
they walk right through it
you know people are seekers who have an
awakening and they say well i know that
can't be it and they keep going
keep going looking for it so
what i have a saying that says that
many awaken but few clear
so as far as from making the jump from
i'm a i'm a guy to um
to i'm well i just
there's just this that jump
here or even to oneness that there's
just oneness and
um i had a very successful oneness
teaching for a couple of years
and then a whiteness pulled the rug out
from underneath me and it was like oh
this is a provisional truth but it's not
the actual truth
and so this
seeing experiencing experiencing oneness
consciously
right so i call that i would call that
conscious
a whiteness and
people come to that they get a glimpse
they get
uh uh they're you know the the the
unknown
unveils itself for a flash or whatever
and they see something
but they never thinking about it again
or they do think about it again but they
can't get it back because there's a
sense
here's the bubble of self-reflection
there's a sense
my i had a awakening like that in 1992
and it was
it was absolutely valid but it was not
long for this world
because shortly after i came to realize
that i was nothing
uh i began to be very impressed with
anything that could come to
know that it's nothing so in other words
it became like oh i got it
and the question is well who are you
talking about yeah
right so it's and and
the egoic principle comes
in and claims that seeing for
its awakening yeah and then ego is left
in the unenviable position of trying
because it because one taste and you
just want another
i have people that email me all the time
and these are spiritual addicts and they
don't know
and they think uh just use me please do
i just need one glimpse just one glance
but
you know i had a friend of mine that
owned a
store and stuff and he took some cocaine
one night years ago in the 80s and um
but just he said it changed it changed
the whole man
he said but the first thing i noticed
that the new man wanted was
more cocaine and that's the way
that we are with spiritual experiences i
just want one until i get one and then i
want another and
we can actually move beyond all that
where
it's unnecessary to have
what people consider to be altered state
experiences or whatever
but a very few of us will move
past a very small percentage i think
i could be wrong i i actually don't know
a damn thing
and socrates and i are agreed yeah yeah
yeah
so we're just talk we're just talking
words are coming out
and they're saying what they're saying
but there's no one saying and no one
listening to them
i'm really glad to have all one of us
here right yeah yeah
yeah so
there there can be
the ones who really penetrate
who go beyond consciousness
because there's consciousness for many
people is the
i mean and i understand that it's the
difference in what you mean when you say
consciousness and all that
but i do find it very confusing because
consciousness seem
you know what are you looking for and
i'm looking for consciousness
what are you looking with i'm looking
for with consciousness yeah
[Laughter]
so so we can move
beyond that and but it's not
what you can notice right now is there's
a sense of being everybody that's
watching this can just notice that
there's a sense of being
there's a sense of aliveness here
there's a sense of presence
and when 20 years ago and i was
listening to edgar tully i thought that
a sense of presence was a prince i love
god's presence or something else's
presence
was what i was supposed to be noticing i
never dreamed it was my presence
and um so
there is
i would like whatever's speaking
ego would like to understand this as
we've said
it can't understand it it's prior to
understanding
and we wouldn't the sense of being is
here
but the sense of being that i can
confess that there's a sense of being
but i
can't confess what that is
because this sense of being if you try
to describe it you'll find that you
can't
because it's prior to whatever you are
is prior to language
yeah so language comes in and it's all
over and that includes these lies that
i'm telling too
but um but folks i'm lying to the very
top of my ability i mean
i'm a professional liar no these are not
your
everyday ordinary half-baked lies these
are
really uh strongly considered and god
approved lives
the best we can use symbols to try to
point the ineffable yeah yeah because
what we
i don't know about you but when i woke
up and to the truth
and it was like
and the first thing i noticed was
well there's nothing to talk about i
know
but the second thing i noticed and this
is not just kind of a joke but
but then shortly thereafter what i
noticed
was that the
trying to do so the attempt to talk
about
was simply the most exquisite thing
on the planet yeah yeah yeah hence what
we're doing here right now yeah
yeah it's true yeah it's just yeah
there's nothing better yeah you know i
just i could
i have slots on sundays then i i walk
into satsang and there's a bunch of
people there
and um it's just like ah it's like
taking a shower or bath it's just
warm shower just so it's beautiful oh
that's a great way to put it
like a warm shower yeah yeah or like a
loving
hug from yes that's right from mom yeah
something like that
yeah yeah this is
so so so well said this is great
another sort of way to just
briefly touch on the the spiritual
addict part
is the i just like how
tony parsons calls them spiritual
lollipops
yeah right you know just like it's like
on the next
yeah and the next one but um there's
also the
like what you mentioned with socrates
who was called
the you know the wisest man in athens
that happens because he knew he knew
nothing
yes um and that's why uh nissar gots the
maharaja also
you know said that the
love is everything and being everything
knowing every
being that and the wisdom is knowing
that you're nothing and then your life
flows between the two
as well what is quite well good mr good
not just my
core teacher and
what he said was i breathe in and i'm
everything
i breathe out and i know things and
between those two my life turns
which is just so beautiful because that
really addresses what you were talking
about
earlier with the simultaneity of things
yes
because we can tend to go when we cut
when we come to see the truth we've been
living as a
we've been living as a human being all
of our lives no i knew i was fred davis
and i knew that a fred davis looked just
like this
until i was about 52. and uh somewhere
around it there
it was discovered that i was not a i was
not a fred davis
after all and that there what not only
was not a fred davis here
there never had been one here
there is that there's only this
but we can when we say only this we can
have a tendency
to feel that we're talking about
manifestation
and i would say in my teaching honestly
uh consciousness god and manifestation
are
synonyms yep and the
but a whiteness is that which is
prior to all of those things awakeness
is it's unnameable but i'm just going to
try because that's so exquisite
that it is the potentiality
it's by its uh it's by its very absence
that there is room for all this presence
yeah the the the silence between the
notes of music
the silence between the notes that's
exactly right
because we can we have a tendency to
think we disregard silence
we disregard space yeah we're all caught
up in the content of this horizon
wow but what noun will come next
right what what will happen next
but i have
oh it's buried i don't see it
you can you can take your time to to
find it if oh you got it
oh yeah yeah okay oh cool
and this comes about because what we
think is we think that space
is just this um annoying thing
that is in between
everything and everything else but
when we start to looking at oneness
when we start really looking at oneness
objectively
then i can't help but notice i mean
how many spaces do you count right now
one space is not what holds everything
apart from everything else space is what
holds
is the glue that holds everything
together
yeah yeah beautiful so you can look at
this and it's two black faces and a
goblet or
it is um two black faces with a white
background
or or a goblet with a black background
and that's called the ruben vase i
believe
okay and so it's a reuben base so which
of these is true
exactly oh yeah both are neither
anyone either way you want to put it but
you can't say one or the other
because it just doesn't work like that
and this doesn't work like that
because where we're living is relativity
and everything exists only by comparison
to something else
like you're pretty sure i'm a fred davis
because i've you've seen
you know when this one happened the
other thing is you're pretty sure that
this isn't
so it's very easy to to home in
on this part and say oh there's fred and
the rest of that is not fred but there's
no opposite to you
there's just you there's no it's
non-duality already
yeah and we can tend to get
lost in the idea that i am just the
vastness oh i'm just the vastness who
cares about the unit is what i call the
bodies
who cares about the unit but
we are not merely the vastness
nor are we merely the little man
we're both so
there is the experience from the from
the absolute that
obviously relativity just doesn't matter
but relativity is our experience
and we honor it if we do not honor it we
do so
there will be suffering will ensue
but it's not that we are
this one or we are that one it's there's
not of this or that
there's just the nameless
and there's no opposite to that nameless
and so when we but that nameless is both
duality
the sense of dual of the dualistic and
the
and non-dualistic at the same time in
other words exactly
right yeah so there's this experience
where
obviously for me for me obviously
this is all me this is i know there's
nothing but me
but then this is me too because this is
an experience
the flatness story continues thank
goodness
and this is what happened you know a
thousand plus years ago was the
was it was how do we put into us into
one symbol how do we put
the non-dual and the dual into one
symbol and that's what you just pulled
up a moment ago the yin and yank
yeah and yeah so
and that's what you were explaining from
multiple faces
of the mountain was just at a moment to
go and you gave the reuben vase example
and
there's a couple places that i'd like to
just
go back to a little bit a moment ago you
were saying that there's kind of
there's these two things that that were
great that you mentioned
that sort of what happens when there's
this
satori or or moksha or nirvana
whatnot that the
the realization as you quote you quote
laozi a lot you know we do as well
you do realize that the tao that can be
named is not the eternal dao
and and lao tza also said that
those who know don't talk and those who
talk don't know
and that's another way to put it as well
and so you learn that both there's
nothing to talk about like you said but
then the second thing
is that you learn that the attempt to
try to talk about
the ineffable is the warmest it's the
worst power
it is like life worth living it is
because
and we basically what we do is we we
play
we play when we talk when we when we
attempt all i can see it's a divine
play yeah it's that leela when we're
when we're
attempting using these symbols to
to uh play with that ineffable it's
it is the warm shower it is that hug
that's what it that's what it it feels
like
yeah someone and and
we'll excuse him on technical errors but
someone wants to put it very sweetly
when they said that
to talk about this with another
someone else on your the same level and
so to speak i mean someone else who's
seen the truth
that that is the embodiment of it
yeah yeah
that's such a good way to put it yeah
yeah
yeah yeah we call it tennis
this is another way to yeah it's it's
it's
tennis and um yeah yeah
and just kind of hitting the volleys
over and it's
just so playful and yeah because there's
just a zillion balls behind us
somebody hits a valley and the ball is
just so
interesting i don't have any interest in
anything right yeah yeah yeah
nor do i have the power to hit it but
it's a fascinating ball i'll tell you
that
yeah wow
like one of the core potentially
we could say if we want to just most
beautiful aspects to the appearance
is when the tennis players
themselves are really strong advanced
maybe
you know world-class level tennis
players where
it is the most beautiful where the game
of tennis that's being played
is so close to the ineffable yeah it
it it bumps your game to play with a
great tennis player
yes and i think that this is the reason
that nes goddard said that the only
thing
that was really necessary uh
for awakening was to spend time in the
company of sages
yes and it doesn't mean it's actually
going to rub off
but if there's a good chance that you'll
just there will be a falling in
there will be a oh oh
oh you know yeah and of
that and right
we're actually this yeah yeah
and in 2020 i spent a lot of time
on just full time dedicating myself to
truth just nonstop as a full-time job
and studying these geniuses that have
lived and died before us and not just
spiritual ones but also the scientific
ones the engineer ones the inventor ones
because it's also interesting to see
their patterns as well and so
the sort of satori that was just a
little
about a month ago now um that just
just you know it creates that uh this is
probably a good
segue into that where there is no longer
an atlas
right actually it's not that there's no
longer an atlas
it's the same that there never was
enough there never was one
because that's a that's our problem is
what will happen to fred when fred wakes
up
well don't worry about it because spread
will never wake up
a itself wakes up doesn't it
yeah awakeness wakes up to the fact that
hell i've been looking for a noun i've
been looking for because they told me
look for something that doesn't come and
go when i went looking for something
that doesn't come and go never dawned on
me that
the only that everything here comes and
goes
other than the space which holds it
right and it's spaciousness that we're
really talking about
not space in the outer space kind of way
but spaciousness
and that of course is
what we really are there's
nothing can exist without this
spaciousness
spaciousness is the mirror in which all
the reflections appear
and this is a pair of reflections coming
to have some high
high-minded conversation about the
mirror
yeah yes do you believe in mirrors
i'm not sure i believe in mirrors that
said the reflection
but the reflection can't exist in the
absence of a mirror
so it's
coming to see
well it's not that we come to see the
truth
it's that the truth comes to see yeah
yeah yeah
oh man and the game that the
truth place to come to see is so
fascinating
the in within this appearance
there is nothing else that i've ever
encountered
where there's an ability for a
singularity to veil itself
and then to pierce that veil and that's
like the coolest
feature well it's and and then we
recognize that it's the veilless veil
yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah
it's just like my bubble of
self-reflection well there's no bubble
there
yeah yeah it's a bubbleless bubble just
like it's the gateless gate
right yeah yeah the veilless veil the
gateless gate
yeah wow
gosh that's such a fascinating yeah it
is
and because it comes right back to what
you were talking about
with the simultaneous right
we simultaneously experience
there's an experience of something that
can only be reported as a gate
gateway and it was in it's just
absolutely remarkable but then it's
recognized there's there's
there's no gate to the guy that this
must be the reason they call it the
gateless gate
it's because there's no gate oh how
about that
we know you know when they said it was
the gateless gate it was like what do
they mean by that
oh well i want to get my teeth into that
i want to figure that out
but in fact there was nothing complex
about it
they were just saying well it's a
gateless gate what does that mean by
that well this is it
but it's so simple that these big
complex brains of ours they don't want
to hear that
they want something to know they want
something to they want something that
the brain can
achieve i'm so
loving the veilless veil and the
gateless
gate and
my question
thought to you around that would be
something like
yet simultaneously as we hold that we
also recognize that
when
we do the
practices that are things like
a theravada buddhism
silent 10-day meditation retreat
no talking no eye contact just going
inward
and making ourselves less
reactive with the monkey mind um and
sort of gaining that real subtlety
that that sort of needed to be able to
to understand
things like this as well um that there
are
these in a sense
there
whether you also you know read the
doubter ching or the
old and new testament or you take some
entheogens maybe some psilocybin to
to undergo some of this flow whatever
these sort of
faces are on the mountain in a sense at
the same time
we recognize that the more sometimes of
these
different tastes that we have the
in a sense the more robust of a lattice
work
that we have that enables us to better
and better
sort of recognize this which is maybe
this is one of the things that
i feel about neo advaita specifically
that is it's it's beautiful
in its direct pointing um yet at the
same time
to to to somebody in a state of maybe an
egoic level of of a contracted energy
in the bubble that uh
there can also be like little the this
the whole thing about the
incremental path versus the sudden path
and whatnot so
how do you feel as well about while we
talk about this veilus veil in the
gateless gate
that there are also this this this idea
of sort of building up
a uh a nomenclature or a lexicon
a concept framework these types of
things across these different
um perennial wisdoms i think we've uh
i think we've had that confused up for a
long time confused for a long time and
here's why i think that
is that we've been pointing toward is it
this or is it like that and it's not
like this or that it's
this and that so what we amounts to
is is awakening an event or a process
it's both it may not be a recognized
event
i mean i have i've i've woken up
i've had hundreds of people wake up with
me and
they and the awakenings range from oh my
god
to you're kidding
one of the most clear one of the
clearest humans i know
woke up with me saying you're kidding
no and that right after that he went oh
i can't
because he had been he's been a
spiritual teacher and everything and
gone around the world and this and that
the other
he just left out the know who you are
part
but when he wake up woke up there was
such context there
that he just blew everything off the map
right he just woke up and it was just
and it doesn't you don't have to be a
teacher for 30 years for that to happen
but it doesn't hurt
right or to be a secret for 30 years it
doesn't hurt
but what we can notice about when we
look at let's say traditional advaita
compared to what we call neo at vital or
sudden awakening
and we look go all the way back to zen
in china and it was like
you know we had the southern school in
the northern school northern people said
it was an event those southern people
said it was a process
anybody that i talked to has been
awakening for some time
and with me they come
and they recognize this
and what they really recognize is not
that they've been awakening but they've
really come to recognize
that they are awakeness itself
and that's the difference because we
talk about
i'm awake but she's not or he's awake
but i'm not
but this awake not awake thing what's
that
what's that oh it's duality isn't it
yeah so what we gave the analogy
in one of your recent talks where you
said that it's like you
you get out of bed in the morning you're
rubbing your eyes and opening up and
somebody's there going
wake up it's like i'm already awake yeah
yeah that's it
right exactly how what
shall i do to convince you that i'm
awake it's and that's what i like to
turn that on tables on that and
sometimes
i'll ask people the uh so
um is there any way if you had to right
now
and you had to convince me that you were
not awake how would you do that
yeah we don't think about it
because we come at it from we come out
through the front door
which is how can i be oneness i mean i'm
just this little thing over here
yeah yeah how can i be oneness but when
we come at it from being oneness
when this teaching i only work with
myself
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what's happening here yeah that
oneness is talking to oneness about
oneness because there's no one else to
talk
and there's no other subject yeah and
right yeah here but
here the obvious is obvious that's all
the obvious is always is
always there's the ability to
to break through and see the obvious
and how you know how does that work we
talk about it and i
even talk about breakthroughs and
breakthrough phrases and
stuff like this but it's
it's not breaking through it's noticing
that there's there's
nothing to break through that there's no
that there's no wall there that we're
not
we haven't reached the top of the
mountain there was never a mountain and
we're just walking along the beach
with everything just flat as right and
but we've been
we've been making up mountains
and and we've been making up adventures
about them
would it be fair to say that there's
that both the simultaneity with the
mountain and the beach i are
at the same time as in the the most
non-dual
is the beach and then the the dualistic
concession
is that there's this mountain yeah okay
absolutely absolutely
okay cool right i'm right with you okay
so but we spend all of our time
and i'll put all of our attention on the
mountain you know
put in any time at all on the beach
what could the ocean is you're teeming
with life and
all this stuff and we're like ah it's
just water man this mountain is where is
what's really cool and
so we spend all of our times all of our
time
caught up in the content of this
arising and instead of
what is it that is experiencing the
content
of this horizon yeah that's the only
thing worth
looking for and you you don't need to
look for it you just need to
notice it yeah because
i heard when i was coming along you know
the the secret never wakes up
and i heard that and i thought now
that's a good thing to know so what i'm
going to do they're going to pretend to
stop
seeking because you can't you can't find
it as long as you're looking for it
so i pretended to not to not look for it
in the hopes that
somehow would trick uh god into showing
herself right
and uh but i couldn't even fake it
it was just such a i mean i was just
doomed to think
to seek that's what i mean i had no
choice i'm sure you didn't either i mean
it just drove me it drove everything
yeah right it did it told me what time i
was going to bed at night what time i
was getting up in the morning what i was
going to do that day and
all of that i mean it was just this
constant um
please yeah right and
it's it's just be just like me right now
asking you so atlas
tell me how do i get to
the chair in my study yeah this is funny
i like this one as well yeah and you're
going well
you know fred you're already in your
chair and you're stuck yeah
yeah oh thanks atlas i appreciate that
and
i understand that i'm on board with that
but
it's not my just not my experience that
i'm in my chair in my study
so what do you do what directions would
you suggest
now right there's there's there's
there's
no we just
is no giving directions to here
yeah yeah that's yeah there you go yeah
there's no giving directions to here
and that's what everybody's asking for
could you please direct me toward here
yeah yeah yeah yeah i could
i could charge you money for it yeah
you sign up for my subscription service
that's right exactly
yeah that's right it's but
so many perverse incentives around that
oh
i know yeah oh yeah yeah
so there's um there's two things
one of them is saint francis of assisi
says that that which
you seek is that which is seeking
that's correct and then the other one is
um
posted these a little while ago as well
that ramana maharshi says that god is
the subject he is the seer
don't concern yourself with objects that
can be seen find out who the seer is
and then punja says the desire for self
slash god realization is like an inner
flame
one must kindle it and then fan it until
it becomes a raging fire which consumes
all one's other desires and interests
and well and and what i would say to
that is he's right
if that's what that union needs to do
yeah yeah which is what it sounds like
both of ours
yeah had it just constantly perfectly
explains what we're where we were
but it doesn't explain everybody so yeah
exactly
yeah yeah yeah these days i actually get
quite a number of students i mean they
don't knock on the door every day but i
get
i get a lot of people that come to me
who have already awakened
and there's a lot of what i call
inherent wakefulness
there but there's no real clarity
so can you describe this so inherent
inherent
wakefulness but no clarity what yeah
what does this mean
in other words there's been an awakening
event
and now the character has a memory of
that awakening event
and it's a very very detailed
deep sort of memory about something very
much like a spiritual awakening
okay but a spiritual awakening can't be
remembered because there's no one there
to remember it
so it's a character's report on the tail
end of some kind of experience where
wow it was really different and for
fred yeah yeah but
i have sometimes once in a while i mean
i have people that will
and i'm not doing private sessions now
but i did i did them for
uh a long long time and you stopped
doing them
i did i didn't know that well and when
i'm i've become overrun
yeah and it's just too much of a
physical burden for this old man
yeah so i still am doing um i still meet
with
i still meet with with regular students
in my i have something called
called continuing students program where
i have a bunch of people that come and
talk to me once a month
that's your song it's with some people
inside no there's a people who have come
and have one-on-one sessions with me
once a month these are people that i'm
sort of okay caretaking and um
and i also and then i have what i call
now is the
this is this is a new development um
which is the skillful means programs
which is our
series which is i do three series i mean
three sessions in three successive
saturdays
but i'm doing it with 20 people instead
of one okay
right because i just came the world
would would
the world would like more of uh fred
than there is fred and i keep moving the
prices up and it just doesn't touch
anything
you know i mean there's still somebody
that will pay
nearly anything for this and uh
it just got to be i'd rather do it for a
bunch of people
for a bunch of yeah yeah and then field
questions as well
and yeah yeah the next two sessions of
the the the following
the first session the good news is they
don't get to talk
and because the the biggest
the biggest problem that i had in
one-on-one awakening sessions
was that everybody wanted to make sure
that i understood their issue
and where their special self was coming
from
and i needed to know about this about
their childhood and this about that
and they couldn't understand it from
this and couldn't can see it from that
so in other words people would pay me a
bunch of money
to help them wake up
my way and they would come to me
and then what they were really wanting
me to do is pay me a lot of money to
wake
them up their way yeah yeah without
noticing and i would sometimes point out
well let's just let's let's look here
we got there's two of us here one of us
has been in
let's just say a thousand awakening
sessions and the other one has
been in how many have you been in a one
who do you think we should be listening
to yep
yep right it's they
they want to help and i did the same
thing i did exactly the same thing i was
just that kind of fool
i cut a fool without with aja shanti i
was awake
but i but i couldn't help it it was not
just shanti oh my god and
uh i wanted i wanted him to see just how
awake i was and that was actually more
important than my question
was for audrey to notice that i was
awake and all this
wow and i get that too and you know so
where what you're really looking you're
you're in the guise of asking the
question
what the question you're really asking
is will you give me confirmation of my
awakening
yeah and sometimes people come to me
that i'm
right out the gate that i can see and i
can give them confirmation but i never
give confirmation
if it hasn't occurred
and most of the people in search of
confirmation are not awake
because what i noticed is that by the
time you get confirmation
you don't really need it it's nice to
have it
it's nice to have a a teacher say okay
you got it this that the other and i've
had a bit of that but
it but it's unnecessary because you
already know who you are
yeah so the confirmation of one empty
unit to another empty unit
yeah is of marginal value yeah
there's another component to what we
were just talking about which is the
it's probably the most
important at least in my understanding
of what is happening here which is
that
in the recognition
of the tennis players that are
doing at high levels
using symbols to play with the ineffable
we recognize that there's the
simultaneity
in that there's this
sort of non-dual beach
as well as this dual mountain
and that the experience of both yes
yeah yeah and that
this is sort of where the
the we already are
the diamond necklace around our neck
only those that are
ignorant seek what's already there
it sort of meets with the
well what are we talking about with that
diamond necklace when there is that
contracted egoic entity that doesn't
understand that
that so and i thing the thing that we
have to come to recognize
is that the egoic entity that we think
we are that we think that exists because
there is
there's no one there there's no entity
that's never going to happen
so what we have is we have an imaginary
character which
has pinned all of his hopes on the idea
that one day
if i keep at this i'm going to come to
recognize that i'm an imaginary
character
he can't get there from here it can't
happen
so it is the seeing through the the
bottle of self-reflection
is when where most people are when they
come to me
they've been in this a while and they
have come to have the
uh and if it's even beyond just
purely intellectual but they have a
grasp of this that we're speaking of
there's a and they and and they do have
a very good intellectual
understanding and we don't we play the
intellectual down too much i think
there's a there's value in that yeah
because i use
the mind to go beyond the mind but i
can't i got to start with that i use the
body to go beyond the body
i use logic to go beyond logic but we
got to start with
tools here and
there is
i forgot what we're talking about now
that's what happens is that this
thread will from awakeness will go to
get some coffee
and then you're left with fred and he
has nothing to share with you
yeah he has a lot to share but nothing
that you would want to hear
so what were we talking about well
that's the true sign
as well where there's so much divine
play that is
where there's been that recognition of
that diamond necklace around the neck to
the degree
of which we recognize how playful it is
to be able to say
great let's hit some tennis balls in the
ineffable and then let's
let's just completely maybe we pl play
in some other way
and we and there's and there's right
without rackets
without rockets yeah let's let's use our
feet for a little while let's
use it without let's try it without
balls without balls
exactly and and that's why
the way that you express yourself is in
a very
playful and it's in a very child-like
and and you have
and that's that's that's another big
sort of highlight
if there were quote highlights of
awakened or
enlightened it it's it has a lot to do
with happiness it has a lot to do with
peace it has a lot to do with like
it has like that afterward but it
doesn't have any necessarily anything to
do with that
prior to i mean i find that misery is
the door emotional
yeah yeah suffering suffering's the
drill sergeant and then yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah let me get back to
the thing that i was talking about a
minute ago when i was okay
because i was talking about the bottle
of self-reflection
so bob comes to me and bob already knows
that so you know and this and they
already know there's no bob
so they come to me and then i start
going on about
you know that there's no bob thing and
they're going when is he gonna get to
the good
part i mean he goes this thing is this
is driving me crazy i already know all
this
and um i have to just be very humble
and couch out of the ego to try to get
it to stay with me long enough
for understanding to take place and when
the understanding of the capital you
occurs
what what is recognized been recognized
by me but it's all written now it's
recognized by me over there as well
which is that the one who knew who knows
there is no bomb
is bomb and that is the booby prize of
nonduality
welcome you have worked yourself all the
way to the booby prize
i'm not telling you it's not that it's
no prize at all it's
that can be useful they can you can you
can moderate suffering from that place
but it's not true so so coming to see
that the only thing that counts is when
a whiteness kind of should see
that there is no bond and that not only
did not bob didn't just leave the room
uh
there's no bob there was never any
bottle and then
when we talked about the fact that when
i say that you are the unborn
that's not a pointer
it's just a comment like i would say i
like your headphones
you are the unborn so and i tell you
that you are the unborn and the and then
the born
wants to know what what's he pointing at
there right is it like they told me
um so fred
you you actually are the
white space i heard that the spacious
emptiness you were the aware space
i heard these things and the only
problem was
i just you know i just didn't know which
space they were talking about
but it didn't know which place they
could be talking about which was this
one
but they it there's only this space
so any idea that i'm gonna lose
leave the space to find this space
you know good luck with that but you're
going to have a hell how long can
awakeness
look for awakeness without having any
luck
forever it and it appears that that
seems to be the way of it for most
people and
your record your sources say 15
of the people who get it get it that's
fine with me i don't care
i just think it's high from my
experience but it doesn't make any
difference
some percentage come a whiteness through
certain and it's not like the unit comes
to see that
it's a whiteness that comes to see that
oh there's no fred there's never been a
fred fred is not going to get this
fred is not going to capture this and be
able to show it off which is what fred
really wants
because it was like you know i wanted to
be the one who achieved enlightenment
and have the teacher notice that i had
achieved enlightenment
and teacher teacher put a gold star by
fred's name
and also give me a big gold star and put
it on my forehead
so everybody can see that i'm the
special one who achieved enlightenment
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just
yeah yeah yeah number two down the tube
that's that's so funny this thing works
backwards
than what the way that we think it does
all of non-duality
the truth let's put it that way the
truth
works backwards in the way we think it
does
and that's the reason you can't teach a
unit how to wake up
it's probably i mean that the unit is
never going to wake that this meat
does not have the capacity to be
enlightened
just like this water glass has no
capacity to be an enlightened water
glass
but it's actually it's not about the
glass it's about the water
and for this walking cadaver it's not
about the cadaver it's about the
animating presence
yeah you've used that before the
animating presence yeah
will you yeah unpack that for us again
the animating presence
is simply what you can notice right now
is
that everybody can do this just you know
just notice that there is that sense of
aliveness we talked about earlier
but there's a sense of aliveness here
and there there's a there's a sense it's
just like a sense of being
here whatever i'm not even saying what
here is
i'm just saying there's a sense of being
and i'm going to
say the feeling will be there's a sense
of being here
and what
we think we are is we think we're the
vehicle
through which that
feeling occurs uh
but we think that that is occurring
to the vehicle instead of through the
vehicle
in other words i really think there's a
friend over here and i've i've got
myself some
some some very high-minded knowledge
about non-duality
and it says spread and and and you don't
understand it
so well let me help you because so now i
have the enlightened thread helping
these poor other
units who just kind of slow units just
can't seem to get it and they will never
get it as long as there is an ego
that they may wake up in spite of that
teaching but they won't wake up because
of it
as long as there is
if the teacher believes
that they are the enlightened ones
whatever
you're dead in the water for you i mean
before you even enter the room
that doesn't mean those people can't be
helpful they can
that doesn't mean we shouldn't have them
because i know this we do
but i noticed that the percentages
let me just take all religions
[Music]
and spiritual circles
and out of all those
how many people really break
through i mean our numbers are pretty
good now you know there's you and me and
a bunch of other people we know
and uh well lots of bunches and i know
about people in other
other continents and all this and that
the other and man we could
fill up a football stadium okay maybe we
could fill up five of them i don't know
but i don't think there's that many more
of us
just just to also to make sure that on
the statistics thing
um it's approximately one percent or so
are um
recognizing the agent list or the
attribute
list yeah and then about uh
15 or so percent or 14 or so percent are
are on the uh the the observer or the
witness
that is experiencing the waves so the
ocean experience and waves and then the
85 percent or so
are on that i'm a separate biological
creature
um yeah yes that was that that's okay
yeah i had that mixed up thank you yeah
yeah and that's why it makes more sense
now because it's it's just
it's a couple football stadiums or or
whatnot um
yeah yeah it may be a bunch of them but
but we can still measure it
with football first yeah yeah exactly
right
exactly yeah yeah and and then there was
probably also another
aspect to this which is that animating
presence is what
is kind of the beach it's what everybody
in a sense has as a
sense of being or an aliveness although
it's
although it's um maybe to different
degrees of
that like aliveness um but
then that one percent is more like the
top of the mountain where there is
a quote you know somebody that's a fred
davis that is able to
host this um this satsang
where he also brings in dozens of people
into it so that
they gain a little bit more of the
pro journey up the mountain while again
it's just wild it's also a beach the
beach is like yeah
and so to hold these at the same time is
is very critical and i think one of the
next things also for us to
touch on is that the the same way
and this this usually is really helpful
for people to
sort of get the
the you know got in a sense it's like a
gondola ride up to the
mountaintop and then the recognition of
the beach and so
the way that that sort of also
uh happens is that
when you do things like give these
analogies with things like the
the dream where for a third of our lives
where
we're sleeping and then we we simulate
out
a a dreamed environment that we
take a first-person perspective into
and there's no there's no difference
between the
observer there and it's physical
environment
that those are one thing the entire
thing as you walk past
the tree as you walk past it and you
keep going in the dream
that tree doesn't stay there and so
in the dream and so the the
analogy to draw for this as well
is that this is on a you know as a buff
so below that
this is in a sense we could say god's
dream or
infinite consciousness yes the core
dream is
when we started getting this thing then
it was oh god it's all a dream i can't
believe it
and it's spreading atlas's dream but
when we really get it
then there's the recognition oh hell
fred and atlas are the dream
that's the dream is i'm dreaming that
i'm afraid i'm dreaming that i'm afraid
there you go
yeah yeah i ain't weakness i'm dreaming
that i'm afraid
and that i'm having all these adventures
but yeah
yeah yeah right and there's a sense of
that but i played with virtual reality
and there's a sense that i could move
imaginary blocks and stack them on top
of other
magical blocks there's that sensation
and everything
you can see it exactly but it's not
that's an experience it's not this
experience
is a is a good teacher but it's not
necessarily
true always either it's very much like
the sense of being there's a sense of
being is that the same thing as saying i
am being
it's really not there's a there's a
sense of being that's a that's a
statement unto itself
there is and there is
a um
as long as we think that this is my
dream and i have a guy how can i break
out of this dream we're screwed
well yeah you're right yeah yeah i mean
that's what i wanted i wanted out i was
suffering and i wanted out of that dream
and then what i got out of was being a
friend
yeah yeah i noticed
oh well i'm not i'm not dreaming that
i'm afraid any longer
and the facts on the ground may remain
the same but i noticed that nothing
pertained
none of them pertain to me
because i am the i am the awakeness i
am the the animating presence
i'm not i am unborn just exactly what it
says
and the whatever it is that's talking
through this unit right now it's not on
planet
it's not on planet its mother's name was
not olive
it has no mother
it's the recognition of
the white source light that is refracted
through the the diamond here and there
and and that is taking on that unique
coloration experience yeah yeah
but to but to go with the mountaintop
to go inward to the source
again it's it's a very much a
self-abiding style
process that leads to these this atma
vitra is
it's not something to say that ah you
know it's this is one of the
one of the things that i see with the
sort of
neo advaita and the pointing out is that
there's a
there are there's it's great to have
this sudden
style of of recognition of the diamond
necklace
already around the neck and yet it's
also
important to recognize that like we were
saying a little bit earlier
just that when you do take the 10 days
to just z
and say no words and just go all the way
down to
the roots of the monkey mind and make
yourself less reactive and make yourself
more give yourself more of that pause
um let's speak we want to be careful
about our
from my standpoint yes yes i would want
to be very very careful with language
because i can't make myself be anything
given the fact that i'm not
yeah yeah and that's what the allows it
allows for change to take
place but i'm not doing the changing
yeah and this is sort of the next
subject as well which is in that dream
analogy itself that the
when when one recognizes that agentless
or that attributeless
then the whole idea of free will just
dissolves
and that's enough yeah yeah because
what the philosophers are asking
themselves is do we have free will or do
we not they've been debating about it
for thousands of years
and i have a different question and my
question is who are they talking about
yeah yeah who are they talking about are
we really talking about
because of the answer there's no one
here to be enlightened and or there's no
one here to have free will
and there's no one here to not have free
will the whole thing is a story
and it's a story that keeps you off you
keeps your eye
off the camera you're so busy looking at
the birdie
that the photographer's got over there
that you
you don't look at the camera exactly
yes yeah which is why ramana said to
pay attention to the seer because when
you ask that when you ask the question
and who are they talking about um
because that can lead somebody to to
right to recognition that
oh my individual contracted ego
and then that leads to further
recognition that e that that that is a
uh that's hilarious that that's that
that's the thinking process versus
if the answer is something like um
god or infinite consciousness and these
appearances of expressions that then the
question uh of free will dissolves it
becomes
it becomes more and more of a um
you know of that question of who are
they talking about that would have that
there's nobody here to have it or not
have it
like you're saying yeah that's yeah that
way of putting it
it's it's an it's an imaginary character
is another way that
you've you've said it as well which has
been helpful the one
the one who desperately wants to wake up
excuse me i'm sorry i didn't hear the
last part of what you said
just that the the imaginary character
has been another way that it's been
helpful it's like it's like in a sense
it's like if like
you know we
another potentially good way to say it
is that it's anarchic
right that that there's yeah there's
like an anarchic
expression to the non-dual yeah and yeah
and that um
to sort of then ascribe that
oh well there's gonna be this this
meaning
or this purpose to that anarchic ness
or that there's gonna be this these
layers of identity around this one this
one this one that is this atlas one
and that fred one and that there's going
to be these you know these
very real seeming layers of of identity
and these real
seeming layers of expression and
appearance
to it that and that there's all this
meaning and all of this purpose to it
it's not to say that um it's it's it's
definitely not
in the nihilism has a lot of um
baggage uh and negative connotation it's
that's why the whole like metaphysical
anarchy it just it sort of
vibes a little bit more like clearly
yeah yeah so maybe that would be a good
place to sort of
um run with you for a bit
is that how does how do how do things
like
a metaphysical anarchy as a as a
descriptor of the ineffable non-dual
how do how does that of the mystery how
does that resonate with you
so i understand that i understand the
phrase and i think that it's a
it's a helpful phrase but we we just
want to be careful because
i have a lot of helpful praises too and
none of our truth i know
i what can we do what can we do i have i
have um
because this teaching is very very
direct but i know people
who haven't i don't know them personally
but i know of a
a couple of teachers that have that
taken
even more direct approach whether it's
just they just it's just
almost ignoring relativity and
the
feel like these phrases
they give us a hand hold and i
understand the purpose of a teaching for
not giving anybody a handhold and we
need that teaching
it's great i admired i respect it
simultaneously i noticed that there are
not a lot of the people in the room
going
oh
so much of that can become a personality
cult
and i don't mean that in a bad way
called i just mean
can it can become a personality teaching
or whatever
if we're not careful because
it is fascinating interesting
but it's for many people those stark
teachings as i would call it are not
particularly helpful
and this teaching is i know everything
i'm saying is a lie
but what i find is i tell
provisional truths which is another way
to just
to to take the the burn off of that
uh off of the la aspect
you said that earlier the provisional
truth and i i really appreciate how
often that you're saying this over and
over again which is that
i know everything that i'm saying is a
lie so it's so
interesting yeah yeah that's it i mean
the the people
people pay me to lie to them and then
and
remarkably even more remote wait wait
it's both it's both
because you're there it's both that
everything that we're saying is a lie
because the ineffable
can't have symbols to describe it
yet it's also true in the sense that
there it the the the non the non-dual
appearance of what this
is is all just happening and so it is
also
the simultaneous just truth of
expression of it yeah yeah yeah
absolutely that's cool it's it's always
both a hand
yeah yeah it's never it's never one or
the other
and that's what that's what people
really want
and they want to
would you just spit it out i just did
but would you tell me is it like this or
is it like
this and it's like it's well it's not
like either one of those
it's got to be one or the other and
that's what they're open to hearing
is one of their theories or the other
one of their theories
but there's not so much openness in
hearing
what's true which is well both of those
things are true depends on where you're
looking from
i mean just like our model of the with
the two faces
you call it something rubik's face yeah
reuben's face just like the reuben's
face
is is that which is true well i mean
it's it's it's both true neither it's
true
but you but certainly it wouldn't be
true to say that one is the truth
over the other yeah yeah to say that the
two black faces or
the vase um the two black faces or the
white vase
one of those is true or neither is true
or both are true that was a really great
um
part in another thing that you said
which was great was that to be
super careful when when we say things
like
that oh the you know the closest that we
can get is that oh it's just simply
this happening or it's metaphysical
anarchy or whatever that it becomes a
personality teaching
i really appreciated you saying that as
well it does
and what we want to notice is that
i'm going to say that i could i was very
lucky i had some
i never stuck with any teacher for too
long other after eckhart tolle and he
never met me
and i never met him so the uh
it's hard but but he's nonetheless i
would say he was my teacher for
quite some time i read just i mean i
read his books i listened to his cds
over and over to just a nauseating
degree to an unhealthy degree
and there but after that
i had a lot of help but i
but most of the help i've had
i felt like peaked
and that and then i found it
not so helpful and even that card i got
to where i couldn't hear him for
anything i mean i'd read his book wasn't
it because there was not enough
directness there
and but then on the other hand there's
too much directness but it's it's it's
it's it
the saying is that when the student is
ready the teacher will appear and i like
to
modify that and say when the student is
ready the teaching
will appear yeah if you're ready
the teaching that you can hear will
appear and the real miracle
about about my students and followers
and stuff
is simply that they found someone they
could hear
and that's that's the great miracle
you know i think i found i found
somebody i could hear i could hear
eckhart but i couldn't i couldn't move
home from there i couldn't
i just couldn't there was i couldn't i
couldn't wake up
yeah and um but i could but i got a
thorough schooling and um
but straight from his
uh straight from his arms i went to
other people that i didn't want to spend
so much time with but that i could hear
them
and there was a rapid really a
a very rapid movement of understanding i
mean
i was i was awake for five years before
i ever started
teaching which is not a bad idea that
that's
i think it's typically ignored but it's
not a bad idea
but i i
i want i wanted very much to be a
teacher
until um until i woke up
and went to see aja shanti you know yeah
i don't think so thanks
i didn't i didn't want to be after that
i didn't want to be a spiritual teacher
and within a month
the first person woke up while talking
to me
i mean it was just so the instant i
didn't want to be a teacher anymore
i got i became one and then i tried to
quit later on i couldn't it wouldn't let
me do that either
so now i just embrace it completely i
love it
this is what i do i wouldn't want to do
anything else
because there isn't anything else yeah
wow that's such a cool part of your
story
is the that
that process of even post
satori or moksha or nirvana just sort of
taking up time to just
be that for even five years is so
critical right after for me
because well we have the this show in
this channel and in a sense it's kind of
it's in it's like a lot of
uh a lot of people
are you know curious like okay well
we're in a sense
they're they're subscribing in a sense
to also the interviewer
as well and so they kind of want to so
if the interviewer has underwent this
satori there it was important for me to
share
and so then i went through this pat this
process of being like
this is crazy there's going to be these
you know these couple
you know direct path teachings and these
videos that we're now
you know undergoing doing these many
different faces to that one end that
we've
been talking about but specifically with
your journey i really loved how you were
just like
nope this is not my thing definitely not
my thing and then you're just
in conversation with somebody and it
just
clicks for them and you're just like
what could be cooler than
literally having people have the click
moment yeah yeah and there there's a um
you can kind of get addicted to that too
yeah
because it is it is it is extremely
pleasurable
and um there's
but uh
the coming to see that i'm always
waking up my i mean i can't wake anybody
up people come to me that want to want
me to make them wake up and i can't make
them
i can help them and i have a lot of
influence
enormous influence but i can't make
anybody do it
i used to have an aaa sponsor who you
know i asked him one time well
you know they don't know that they're
really um
he wants to to quit drinking it and he
said no he wants to want to quit
drinking
and he said all we can do is help them
when they really want it he said if we
could make them want it we'd be
millionaires
and that's the way this is is that
i can't make you want it enough i can
make it to where if you want it
it becomes yeah like exactly
pour in a glass of water exactly exactly
yep yep and that's also why you said
that you know the
the perennial wisdoms
go something like when the student is
ready the teaching appears but then
the other interesting aspect to that is
that when the
when this when the student goes through
this gateless gate
this bayless veil that then the
the student themselves
becomes you kind of made that funny
reference where the teacher
puts a a golden star on the students
which is so
funny that there's that that process and
then um
but then yeah the student in the self
turns and says
okay well now to sort of you know to
to now that i've recognized that diamond
necklace around the neck it's like
now they're sort of a process of like
becoming a
a teacher as well to the to those that
are ready
also to and those who are drawn to it or
drawn to it and then
there's one more um sort of part of that
perennial wisdom that's so fascinating
which is that
the at because as you know um
the students teach you all the time
as well and so it's fascinating because
that's why one of the perennial wisdoms
is that
the teaching is made with through the
process
itself and and i think that that's also
i tell people very hard for me i mean
it's very
hard for me to get too confused because
every couple of hours one of you guys is
going to pop in and straighten me out
right
multiple sessions a day so i can only
get so confused
then i've got somebody coming in
teaching
and it's like oh i see and
it's and you know
people are paying me to keep me awake
[Laughter]
it is a great racquet yeah yeah he looks
so funny
yeah that's that's the truth so yeah
yeah that's a that's a great way to also
i have a i have a joke
that um uh that
god decided when he you know when he
looked down
that you know so i'm gonna go ahead and
make that guy a teacher but i can see
this is a troublesome unit so i think
what we're gonna have to do is we're not
gonna be able to wake him up once we're
gonna have to wake up this one
all the time after three fourth time
five times a whole day whatever it is
so what are we gonna do so i'll make him
a teacher and then students will come to
him
and they'll wake his ass up four or five
times a day yup
you know and that's the truth from the
mouths of babes
yeah yeah that even the one
one really good question
there from my also even just
brief experience with this even in the
last just
month that the when there's somebody
there that is really truly
like asking really good questions which
is usually what
which is what my role has been for the
last
five years trying to get to this point
right it's that's
and that's usually what the what the
teachers tell me
is that they say that i can tell that
you by asking these
really enthralling questions that you're
getting that you're getting it that you
that you're
and so you're getting it and so and and
the teaching
is rising to another level in the face
of skillful
questions yes which is the same thing
with nondual inquiries that
is it just because ultimately it's
only the only awakeness can inquire
because there's nothing about a
whiteness yep
yep but when we in when we actively
inquire consciously inquire as the
whiteness
then it's completely different than
actively
inquiring as a fred
right trying to find out the secrets of
fred
and what am i what is because well
because i thought well i thought rominal
was telling me
what is fred really yeah i know and
that's the same
same thing with the um with the with the
the delphic maxim on the top of the
temple of apollo
at delphi that says know thyself because
that's sort of in modernity it's treated
like the self-help thing like with
self-actualization
that's right know thyself okay cool who
is
atlas what is atlas going to build into
the world
yeah versus the in versus the inward
process yeah
yes yes the um
there is there if you go into any
bookstore there's a big self-improvement
section
i have you know if my books are there
they are
in this in the self-demolition
section the unsubscribe the unteaching
section yes exactly i'm teaching the
unspiritual teachings
yeah it's because there's
you know it would be fine to
have um what are the self-actualization
if there was a self yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so it's always going to be and if you
were
if you were doing it instead of it doing
you instead of it doing you
that's right that's because that's what
the exactly that which is that
we all think that we contain
consciousness
it's right up here yeah i got to protect
this unit because if this unit goes down
consciousness disappears and um
but consciousness has got us yeah yeah
and it's consciousness that's really
having the belly laugh right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
and that's who's always surprised by
when awakening occurs it's never the
unit it's never the character
oh yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah it's
always oneness
yeah oneness is so surprised because
in all of its grandeur and splendor one
is just never even considered the idea
that oneness looked like this yeah yeah
exactly i know
and i know that's a stretch but if we
look at it
i mean the thing about oneness the real
tip-off for me
is that there is just one of them so
it since there is just one of them
there's not room for a
oneness and a fred or oneness and an
atlas yeah
so what comes to be surprised is not
fred and atlas which what we had in mind
is it not right yeah i can't write i
can't wait
for the shift and um but it's a
whiteness that is surprised
and uh because actually if you look at
it i mean it's a stretch to think that
this is oneness
but since it's just one of them
is there any possible way that this is
not oneness
yeah like the better question like the
fish that's
that's that's going where where is the
ocean
where is it where is it where is it
where is it
and then and then once once there's sort
of that oh
and then it's like this relaxing and
expanding
that happens and it's just yeah it's
just so nice for
the you gotta be careful you can end up
with some lazy fish that and that's
that's that's that's the middle path
that's the middle way that's
the the tantric path that's sahaja
samadhi you
you weave your enlightened realizations
into the social fabric
uh you know that's this is the thing is
that there's
there's the like we keep like this is
this is always these jokes that we make
is that when
you know when you know if you and i were
here in the same room together and
you you know you were to say that you
know
hey atlas hand me the microphone right
it's not like i'm going to say that
there is no atlas
well there's no atlas here somewhere
else here and i'm not going to walk on
the street
and just pretend like that that there's
no cars
that are going to be right and so and so
there's like there's this
in a sense it's like this middle path
where there's like the sweet spot it's
like the goldilocks zone in a sense
and another way to think about it that
that i've seen with this mountain
analogy
that's been really fascinating is when
you get to the snow right the snow can
be sort of like what you think is like
enlightenment a little bit and the peak
the absolute and whatnot but with that
snow portion of enlightenment
there's always if you've heard about the
people that go up everest and whatnot
there are all of these
crevices and the crevices can be covered
by
the fresh snowfall and so you don't even
know that it's there you step in and
you've dropped 40 50 feet to your death
or something
right and so the idea is that to
sort of to know to sort of as you
as as this sort of the the musical notes
are being played
is there's this like vigilance for these
crevices where it's like
they're yeah it's not like i'm gonna
just yeah yeah
go and you'll become a lazy fish as you
said yeah
yeah thomas thomas jefferson said that
the price of freedom
is eternal vigilance and i am in
complete agreement
interesting price of freedom is eternal
vigilance yeah
yeah there has to be this is all about
vigilance and and that's and that's
another
sort of um there
there's like the self-discipline
community as well like
jocko willink and um
and um
there's uh there's another there's
another one
uh as well that has been making
uh sort of profound waves but
they're sort of um
another way to describe what is being
said with
is is discernment is discernment
yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah that
eternal vigilance is just that yeah
discernment is
and that's why it was called nettie
nettie you know not this not that
but yeah it is this it is that and like
that's
sort of like the closer and closer you
get to that
inevitable so when somebody says you
know well maybe you should go and
you know uh get your you know go and
and get a loan and go and get the next
car go and get the next house you know
and
and it's like when you have discernment
you sort of recognize
that no it's not i'm not seeking
externally for
a happy object um to make me happy i'm
i actually already know that i am that
eternal
happy um that is within and that um that
that the discernment is
is critical and even with the whole
unsubscriptions
um aspect to it as well you can think
about it with that
that that three pound uh arrogant um
organ that um that the
the inputs that come into uh
in in whether it be the the
the drinks or the the food
or the information um if if we're
watching
the polarization propaganda that's gonna
be
highly cancerous to um to any
peace and to any happiness um
and it has nothing the polarization
propaganda has nothing to do with both
and has nothing to do with that
philosophy
or that understanding at all um has only
to do with i'm right and that they're
wrong and that um and so
the yeah there's just like i'm glad that
we're
sort of on on discernment here and that
you know the lack of discernment
the lack of discernment is just
astonishing
yeah it is right i think it is it's just
there's so
little actual discernment within
spirituality when you have lots and lots
of followers who find something that
they can follow and that does my
discernment for me
and oh no you put your you put that in
somebody else's hands
you take your spirituality and put it in
somebody else's hands you're in trouble
you can find somebody else who can help
you with it
but you know but don't attempt to
offload it and that's what happens
y'all got me well i have me a spiritual
guy yeah
like i have a mechanic i have a great
mechanic
and i have a great i have a great
spiritual guy i want to introduce you to
and it it's you can turn just turn over
your
spirituality to him he'll show you the
truth then you'll have it you can go
uh climb everest like it's a because
if we're not careful enlightenment can
become
uh just an another item on a bucket list
for ego because the guys just wants to
swim the amazon
climb the you know the
himalayas and wants to do this
deep sea dive and do all this stuff
and right there on the list somewhere
there's going to be an enlightened
enlightenment right
and for many many people and these this
is where i
come in and i say many awaken but few
clear
yeah i've helped people a lot of people
build up their
bucket list you know i mean achieve a
notch on their
bucket list but it was never my
intention to do that
that was not what i was after but it was
what they were after
and i can't there's and as little i can
do about that
the and not anything i should do because
that's what we need
at this point how do we know that's what
we've got
right and
there's you know you can argue with what
is if you want to
but no i can't i don't recommend it
no no no no fighting against the
the waves versus surfing on the crest
that's sort of the
analogy yeah yeah
yeah when when you say the awakened but
not
clear it's in a sense a lot like what we
were saying
in the sort of analogy that we've been
referencing throughout as well which is
that
when the that egoic contracted
drop recognizes itself as the ocean
and it's the ocean experiencing the
waves
that then that can be thought of as
maybe there are these tastes these light
bulbs
have as flickered and then for it to
sort of stay
on in a sense the entire
uh observer and experience the
witness and the experiencing process
itself
um is rejected as
as as an appearance as an illusion as a
dream
as maya and that the
uh the only thing that is is no thing
it's you know all all
just indescribable ineffable um
happening and that the this is that that
sort of
last um bit is what you could maybe say
as
clear um yeah that and
come to see we come to see this thing
we can come to see through ever more
subtle layers
and the yeah which is what we're doing
right now because
i i don't want to there are no rules to
this thing so i'm not making rules folks
but i'm just going to tell you from my
experience which is pretty
pretty pretty fast um
is that if you don't pursue this thing
you will lose it
in other words you can't really lose
what you are yeah but you sure think you
did you will experience that i had it
and i lost it
and i spent 14 years in that predicament
in between 2002
between 1992 and 2006
and it's a miserable place to be
and uh i mean i was awakened for five
minutes and i wanted to rest on my
laurels for the rest of my life
right that oh oh oh i've got it fred's
got it now
but there's no one here to get it
there's there's
getting it and and
there's this present verb of getting it
but there's no one here that's got it
and everybody is
so interested in graduating from
spirituality
that they don't want to go to school
yeah and also to recognize that there
isn't even the graduation process i'm
sure
you can say this is that there is no
graduation that's exactly
there's no graduation yeah the moment
that
you s that we in a sense um
stop fanning the the fire um
is the the moment that um maybe that
there is a
that a contraction can can come back or
a layer of identity
can in a sense come back i know that
there's this that
that there is this piercing of the
veilless veil
the gateless gate that that that does
when when that happens that
many people say that you there's no
going back
um that kind of a thing uh but there is
also
a going back there is there is you
cannot
unsee this thing but you can experience
that you would
because because all you had to do is
make it
an object that the unit had
fred fred woke up yeah something
yeah you go ahead and start treating me
as an unlike being if you'd like i mean
yeah which means
it's really different please and
right for grapes yeah right
exactly exactly yeah yeah that's what i
was looking for you know i didn't get
that
i mean i was hot on the spiritual trail
in the hopes that
you know i could uh make some money and
get some girls
right and it's just i wish i wish it
were less
shallow but that's what that was that
was a lot of my motivation uh and it was
a lot of my motivation for a long time
and which is i mean
of course it's just ridiculous yeah
but these things do what they do yeah
and
you know and and the thing is is that
it's all about
the just like a a flower vase
you can have a beautiful vase and that's
nice or or you can have a tin
can it's really about the flowers
it's not about the vase and this is a
tin can if ever there was one
but it's not about the tin can
it's about the flowers yeah and the
and and awakeness has
no pride you just as soon use an old tin
can as a shiny new
black blonde glass box
[Music]
interesting so you in the if
francis lucille who was the teacher of
rupert
spyra um francis has this great
expression he calls it the eternal
fireworks
of the happening and and it's
interesting in what you just said fred
you say that um rather than the you know
this the
the vase it's that the flower um
and it's interesting because what the
fireworks can be thought of as
it's that that fireworks and not the
cartridge that's
that's the con
that that gets that it gets sent up in
and we got a bunch of vases
and all the other vases have beautiful
flowers too and they're looking at this
space
and and they're you know the the the
central and they're thinking
god what beautiful flowers how can i get
there yeah yeah exactly but i changed
myself into becoming beautiful flowers
yeah and they're already beautiful
flowers they're already a dozen
beautiful flowers looking at your
beautiful flowers saying that
can i get some of those beautiful
flowers yeah right
you're already a gorgeous firework
looking at another gorgeous firework
wondering how can i
be a gorgeous fighter how can i
make noise in color like that right yeah
yeah how can i
how can i really charm people like that
or whatever and it's like
well you know when i when i when i said
told you i wanted to
try to stop teaching because
when i went to see aja and i was white
when i got there
but i wasn't but i'm but the clarity
then was nothing like it is
yeah yep and
the
what happened was i wanted to
i didn't want to teach because i
couldn't figure out how i answered all
those questions
right i mean that looked to me like the
most stressful job in the world
because somebody live a question you
know you in my own mind i'd be having to
go
well let me think about that a little
bit what can i put together to answer
this question successfully
or whatever it never dawned on me that
it wasn't manja answering
that it was certainly coming through aja
ness
exactly yeah but it's the thing itself
is just
i sometimes say this is like a pillsbury
doughboy
you poke it in the stomach and words
come out
that's the same thing with the issue
yeah you push it in the stomach and
words come out
yeah and but it had nothing to do
but but this unit had nothing to do with
the formulation
of those words except for that there's
because the body but the bodies
themselves are conditioning
so that conditioning is going to
influence what comes out
like i'm telling you the truth the
greatest truth that i can but
at the very best it's the straight truth
plus the fred spin
mm-hmm you can't they can't not be
fred's spin on it
because it's coming through this unit
and there's conditioning there
that affects it and that can be that can
conditioning
is uh
these bodies want to get rid of all
their conditioning
but better watch what you want there
because
the bodies are conditioning itself and
if you
succeed and get rid of getting rid of
all your conditioning then the unit will
pass
the unit will die because the unit
itself is conditioning
and it's yeah but it feels like i've got
to get rid of all my conditioning
i've been told that they tell me i got
to get rid of all my attachments
good luck the layers
the layers are the unique prism that the
source light is refracted through
and although it does help to
undergo a process of getting to those
roots of of the monkey mind to
be able to create a longer gap be less
reactive with the longer gap is really
what
also helps with that discernment that we
were talking about
earlier and to sort of have
like i really appreciate how you said a
little bit ago that
there is more and more an eternal amount
of
layers of subtlety and clarity to
this those are you know i've had i have
people it didn't used to happen in early
my early practice teaching practice
because i just don't think there was
like an attractive enough clarity over
here
i mean i don't i really don't um but now
i regularly have people who
i mean it's not every day but i mean
it's regularly
uh people like anywhere in the world who
was
walking down the street one day and boom
right
and it just the awakeness unveiled
itself
and they were just and they were never
seekers never looking to be seekers
never thinking about being seekers
and boom awakening occurred and uh
they've got a full dose of whatever the
hell this is
but there's no clarity there and there
can be a lot of confusion
and there can be there can be enough
confusing that you
people find a way to suffer through
anything and um
so you know you can even suffer with
that i'm sure
but the clarity that comes after it it's
there's a difference between
understanding
which this can't be understood
and the understanding which is with a
capital u
i don't know of a better name word for
it but even though it's not
understanding but there isn't
there we know there is an understanding
here
yeah i can tell from talking to you that
you were part of this understanding
right and because you can't
you know somebody i walk into a room and
somebody just stays silent i might judge
them as well that's quite the awakened
being over there
and uh but they come in and they start
talking
i don't know yeah yeah exactly
exactly yeah as long as you got your
mouth shut you're a mystery
you open your mouth and start talking
there's no more mystery
and it doesn't take much yeah yep
and it's that's why the
you can say it's a
it's like a surgical precision that has
to be
uh you with the with the discernment of
the logos of the words uh
in order for that uh judgment of the
mis of what was the mystery in silence
to be
of uh oh they
have closer to the capital u
understanding yeah yeah so there is
in my teaching i use the word precision
a lot
because and i talk about the that that i
don't know
i use years ago i mean i was a poet
before i was a mystic
i was already a mystic and didn't know
what i thought it was yeah yeah yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
but there's a great love of precision
in language here because of those years
of the poet
and you know you just you can sit there
and agonize over what
do i want to say and or for or whatever
it is
yeah you can agonize over even
and the precision of the language
language will not get you there
but it can get you so close
that if you're just willing
to just just step over
i mean when i first started started
talking i used to get a lot of explosive
awakenings
that's because people used i i couldn't
get you all that
i could get you pretty close to
awakening and but you still had to leap
off the mountain
in order to get to the other mountain
but now there's a bridge
you just get the top of this mountain
you walk right on over to the other one
there's not much of a leap you have to
take there's not that sudden
jarring change of state which is
because you're coming when you're
talking about with me you're seeing it
very very very slowly and easily and
slowly and easily and slowly and easily
and then that momentum builds but it
used to be
so and as a result of that i had fewer
and fewer
explosive awakenings almost none anymore
because it's just
it's not as it doesn't there's not that
same
shock because i know i'm working with
awakeness i mean i will i will have
people notice the sense of being
prior to a session because i'm putting
myself on notice over there okay i'm
here
and the jig is up
right a whiteness comes to a whiteness
awakeness has no resistance to awakeness
but a weakness that thinks it's a fred
davis
only so helpful
as you mentioned a couple times as well
there's
a one of the best ways as you said with
nissa gaza's maharaja as well is that
the just sitting in the presence
is already like a vortex in a sense
and so in in a sense we could say that
at the top of that mountain
is that uh as we
in the layers of subtlety and clarity um
there's more and more of a vortex that
comes in the sense of
pulling the
these in in pursuit of that mountaintop
up with and that that's also been
something that's
it's like the quality we mentioned this
as well the quality of
your life in many ways is the quality of
your questions
and that if if we're willing to ask
these questions of what is
i what is my source we're willing to be
honest with ourselves and few of us are
and i was not particularly known noted
for honesty in my life
but uh but now there's a
there's a sort of rigorous honesty over
here
at least in this and at least in this
one area
where i can tell i can't tell myself i'm
not
myself i can't tell myself i'm not this
i can't tell you
i can't you know the if from a fred's
point
eye point of view i could introduce fred
to this very scene
and it will just suck out loud because
it'll be coming for it'll be fred's
eye's view of the world and the world is
never gonna be
the way that fred thinks it should be
but from this point of view
when i change where i'm looking from and
now i'm looking for the eyes of weight
of awakeness
where there's no actual point of view
there's just view
or just viewing then i can't find a
problem here
i can't find anything broken or out of
place or missing
nothing seems to be
actually there appears to just be what
is and
what is it feels to me like it there's
it can only be as it is
yes yes and that's why the rinsai zen
had the
the question of what at this moment
is lacking yes that's it that's right
yeah what this moment is like absolutely
nothing nothing
nothing yeah
fred this has been such an honor and a
pleasure
oh and i've really enjoyed it you've um
you're
you you you're the quality of your
questions has been really really
excellent and
and the quality uh of
your how do i put that
but tennis playing dialectic yeah
yeah the quality of your tennis building
thank you for bubbling me out of that
your tennis play playing is very high
and i've
really enjoyed uh going back and forth
it really is it's just what could be
better
yeah like you said that that's the
second one the first one is
is uh there's nothing to talk about and
the second one is
the coolest thing is to get as close as
we can with symbols to
to yeah that's it yeah that was a great
point
well thank you very much for having me
yeah i'm tickled to death
me too yeah tickle to death
that's another good one yeah i've been
i've been taking the unborn is tickled
to death
yeah yeah
go figure yeah exactly wow
um i've been yeah i've been taking so
many uh
great notes of reference throughout the
convo and
um and that's been a great
reference point throughout the animating
presence
the awakeness both and the dream analogy
metaphysical anarchy but not having it
become a personality teaching
the the non-duality of the beach with
the duality of the mountain
that was a really really good one the
veilless veil the gateless gate
you know yeah yeah um and the net
and sense of being and
i'll uh i'm i'm looking forward to
exploring more together um where
where are you based i'm in south
carolina perfect south carolina cool
we're in los angeles the very center of
the non-dual universe
have they not exactly yeah that's right
south carolina that's where it's at cool
yeah hopefully um once things settle a
bit
closer to maybe the summer and whatnot
it would
be awesome to be able to do one of these
in person and
another round yeah you're you're right
i'll be great we really really
appreciate you a lot fred and thank you
and also for
for all of those that watched we love
you
so much thank you for watching thank you
for tuning in we are super appreciative
we would
we would love to hear how you feel about
the the tennis
uh and what fred was teaching us about
on the
in the comments below come play tennis
come play tennis yeah
exactly and let us uh we would love to
we would love to hear from you so let us
know and then also
like the video if it brought you value
subscribe if you haven't
share the video with other people as
well and
also check out the links in the bio
below awakeningclaritynow.com is down
there also fred's
author page on amazon with all of his
books you can check those out as well as
his youtube channel
go and subscribe to him and check out
his videos they're excellent
and i think fred mentioned throughout
the interview as well that he's
doing the um the smaller group
yeah i'm doing small groups and i'm
doing i still do satsang every sunday
everybody is welcome that i got an email
this morning morning that was addressed
to betsy and just said how do i meet
fred
and i wrote about some kind of socks on
and it's
there there's still i'm very actively
teaching and i'm
teaching every day and so
uh i'm just not doing exactly the same
thing
as a most operandic
to help people wake up i have i have new
ways that they're simply more efficient
yeah and they're less taxing on this
whole unit
yep yeah yeah exactly and i haven't had
all
i've really had about all the hand-hand
combat that i'm
looking for the egos right yeah yeah
exactly the wisdom of that and then also
the wisdom of the
the internet with the ability to go one
to many um
yeah as well which is really profound so
yeah it is it's beautiful
yeah thank you again so so much fred
thank you
thank you my great pleasure thank you
thank you thank you
i'll see you when i see you thank you
and thanks everybody for tuning in we
love you so much thank you
and much love we will see you soon
peace everyone